[Musique]
ok qui donnent aujourd'hui vegas
derniers jours départ demain mais encore
plus là une chance de vous montrer utile
ou les sites la merde
yachvili bordel j'en ai pas parlé lancer
un nouvel ordinateur complètement dingue
xps 13 13 24 fouche vous emmène avec
mort par un petit tour l'an passé pour
pallier waro donc juste hier vous allez
moi s'étendent il est assez incroyable
il fait de belles promesses il les tient
et il ya un tout qui change le décor
[Musique]
paris
l'essm en bout par le bruit d'une
nouvelle espèce 13,2 d'elle je pèse 13
2020 hors d'elle on situe un petit peu
ses marques et plein de choses via la
party gaming avec alienware ya la partie
ordinateur ya plein de trucs et dans cet
univers déjà parlé souvent d'ailleurs
des ordinateurs xps parce que je trouve
vraiment coup et là ils ont présenté aux
crs 2020 une nouvelle version c'est un
xps 13 13 pouces un peu plus de 13
pouces dans un châssis de 11 pouces
ils ont réussi un petit peu a poussé les
meubles en tout cas plutôt à réduire
l'encombrement
c'est vraiment impressionnant ce que
fait d'elle la dessus il ya deux ans
lorsque j'avais commence à vous parler
des xps 13
on avait la petite kanak était
positionné juste en dessous de l'écran
ce qui fait qu'en ce qu'on vous filmez
envoyer votre pile comme ça si vous
aviez des pôles d'année ce n'est pas
très beau et il n'était pas terrible
l'année dernière ils ont réussi à
changer ils ont une nouvelle technologie
evault de la caméra qu'ils ont intégré
les dernières dans leur ex ps en 2019
vous aviez les caméras en sang
retrouvées dans d'autres modèles
m'aurait pas celle à ce moment là
c'était vraiment vraiment cool et tout
ça que d'abord extrêmement fin et là il
va encore plus loin en 2020 avec un
ordinateur qui déborde toujours plus
fins sur le haut toujours plus fins sur
le bas c'est mieux intégré c'est joli
c'est élégant et ça j'aime bien et en
plus ce qui est bien c'est que même au
niveau du châssis ils ont réussi à
réduire à rendre tout ça plus compact
une machine toujours plus performantes
un truc est vraiment cool un produit qui
est vraiment vous rien que pour ça rien
qu'au niveau design en tout cas c'est
une machine qui est vraiment comme et là
je parle que du design que ça produit
extrêmement performant vous pouvez
vraiment faire tourner plein de choses
dessus c'est un produit compact permet
très facilement review partout et je
trouve vraiment cool
[Musique]
c'est ça qui est cool sur plein de
points et je vous dis notamment tout ce
qui va être en termes de performances
mais serait que ce qui fait la grande
force de ce produit ça reste quand même
son design surtout des morts qui sont
beaucoup plus fin on a un ratio écran en
façade qui fait 91 5% alors je passais
des chiffres qui vous parle mais ce
qu'on voit c'est que c'est vraiment faim
sur le côté ses fins en eau ses fins en
bas ça c'est vraiment cool dont une
esthétique qui vraiment incroyable mais
surtout cette année il ya le bord
inférieur qui était réduit
et cela significativement par rapport à
la version d'année dernière l'écran
aussi changent
faut il avoir un format 16 9ème on a un
format 16/10 toujours plus grand surtout
confortable pour regarder du contenu
multimédia
alors je vous dis xps 13 écran 13 pouces
en fait c'est un écran 13,4 pouces vous
avez différentes résolutions une
résolution 1920 par 1200 on est sur du
full hd plus et vous avez une résolution
4k eu hd3200 par deux mille 400 pixels
il existe aussi une version avec un
écran tactile
donc un projet qu un design qui est
vraiment vraiment réduit hyper hyper
cool avec un châssis en aluminium et des
fibres de carbone en termes de
performances on est sur un intel core
pour perdu 6 3 jusqu'au iseg qui 3 et 5
i7 de 10e génération on peut monter
jusqu'à 32 gigas de ram et jusqu'à deux
terrains en ssd pour le stockage
ce n'est qu'au terme de performances en
termes de stockage en terme de calcul on
peut vraiment choisir la machine qui
vous corresponde correspondre aux
besoins offerts plein d'applications
différentes je sois de l'édition de
bureautique
notre performance de 3500 marche très
très bien vous prenez 16 giga de ram
vous prenez un terreau à 1512 giga de
stockage en fonction de vos besoins en
fonction de ce que vous avez comme
besoin aujourd'hui
mais ce que vous aurez comme besoin
aussi à l'avenir donc ça c'est vraiment
cool c'est maria mesalles et pour une
fois de plus de ce que vous allez faire
la lutte aux qu'il faut vraiment
intéressant est ce que nous annonce
d'elle là dessus c'est l'autonomie une
énorme autonomie qui monte jusqu'à 19
heures en lecture vidéo en local
alors 19 heures ça me paraît énorme tu
ferais moi de pouvoir tester pour vous
rembourser effectivement là dessus il ya
une énorme boulot qui a été fait par
dell pour effectivement proposer une
machine performante lys entre autonome
des parcours des coûts petit format epub
bac est vraiment très très très très
très grosse affaire là dessus d'année en
année elle va beaucoup plus loin avec
les ex ps avec l'express 13,7 va durer
lire xps 13 de 2020 c'est encore un tour
de force
moi je suis vraiment vraiment bourse et
qui paiera les champs c'est une très
très belle machine j'aimais déjà
beaucoup
les modèles xps des années précédentes
je trouve qu'en 2020 ils vont encore
plus loin je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez vous est ce que ces radiateurs
qui pourrait vous séduire
est ce que vous pourriez vous tenter à
savoir en plus que vous avez du mi6
dessus on a vraiment les dernières
techno ça marche c'est efficace en terme
de connectique vous avez deux
connectiques usb c'est thunderbolt roi
vous pouvoir brancher aussi un disque
dur externe pour venir travailler dessus
en cinq ans ball pro avec une grosse
vitesse d'écriture et de lecture prise
jack lecteur de cartes microsd pour les
créatifs qu'on pourra vraiment prôner
qui est vraiment complet et en plus même
sorti une version pour les développeurs
vous aurez pas de windows disent vous
avez un nouveau tout de suite bon ok
s'adresse pas du monde s'est nichée mais
en tout cas on voit qu'il vise vraiment
large au niveau de ce produit j'ai
grandi à tort qu'il est dispo dès
maintenant la laddh et maintenant on
pouvait y avoir si vous voulez le tarif
de base vont commencer un petit peu
moins de 1500 euros
ça reste quand même un certain prix et
les étapes dans une machine et qui
vraiment bien qu'ils feraient mon top et
que en tout cas moi comme ça j'ai hâte
de tester j'ai vraiment envie de voir ce
qu'un enfant pouvoir réellement ce
qu'elle peut donner en ayant pris en
mains en ayant touché on ayant regardé
en ayant manipulé
je trouve vraiment cool surtout en
connaissant la qualité de dell au niveau
de justesse à mon avis dès 2020 vraiment
voiliers du bourg a vous de me dire ce
que vous en pensez en bas on commenté à
vous de marquer tout ça moi je trouve
vraiment cool
dites moi si ça pourrait vous intéresser
dites moi si vous avez un modèle
antérieur est ce que vous avez la petite
caméra qui situé juste en bas est-ce que
vous avez vu les bords extrêmement pas
de ce modèle qu'est ce que vous pensez
du design mark et moi tout ça en bas des
nourritures et par l'etec parce qu'il ya
plein de choses à dire ici ou crs
il y a
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]